Hello, I
'm Aonuma, the producer of The Legend of Zelda series. The
Legend
of Zelda breath of the wild
sequel has been announced when it
will be released.
I would like
to change the release to the spring of 2023.
I
am very sorry to everyone who is looking forward to it.I
told you last time that the stage of the sequel will spread
not only to the ground field in the previous work breath of the wild but also to the
sky.  However
, the world of Haccho is not only that, but the
new encounters and new games that await you there
are
more diverse than the previous work.
We will continue to do our best to work on it,
so please
wait for
a while.
Thank you for this announcement.